okay so um i see some people making
progress
uh not too many people are finished but
enough people are that i think
if you're all on the way i can help you
out a little bit now
let's have a look at this think back to
you i've deliberately left out working
for question one on the board
think back to question two oh sorry from
four question two think back to question
one
and what substitution we introduced to
make things better
how does it work right on the left hand
side
what substitution did i introduce can
you remind me because i did rub it off
but you can see it right
i let you equal
the thing that's underneath the square
root underneath the radical right x
cubed plus one and that kind of did the
j
lovely you can't quite pull the same
trick on question two
can you because if you say i know i'll
just like
do the same thing that i did before i'll
do what i've done in advance the
extension one and i will take a pattern
algorithm and i'll just do it again
right i'll as
we mouse teachers like say i will crank
the handle okay
why doesn't it help to just take the
thing underneath the square root and
just make the substitution
because it's the same preview yeah it's
if i go
let x equal u or let u equal x rather
um we haven't materially changed the
question you get ah du
on u plus square root of u it's like i'm
not even
back at square one like i've squared
zero i haven't changed anything
okay so therefore has someone come up
with a better substitution to make
how foreign letting u equal the square
root of x that's worth a shot right um
sometimes you have to try things
like i'm not sure it's going to go let's
see what happens now we know
that this is x to the power of a half so
to go ahead and change our variable of
integration our derivative
you might be able to do this in your
head well enough having done a
sufficient number of times in advance
for extension one
can someone tell me what the derivative
is right off without any form
one over two root x is correct right i
got that half the one over two i got
that from
the index that's implied up here and
then why is the root x on the
denominator
there you go it's it's x to the power of
negative because i reduce it by one
if you're confident enough to do that
and maybe this particular one comes up a
lot and great but if not like we've
known how to change things back in the
next one to make things easier for
ourselves
okay now at this point at this point
i'm kind of i hit a pause right because
i'm like over with this one right when i
did my du
on dx and then i thought oh that's
convenient i somewhat chose this
particular u
because i knew that u dash appeared
without much
change in my original integral this is
not the case over here i don't neatly
see
some one on two root x appearing right
so can anyone make some suggestions
like i can't say for example uh well it
wouldn't be very helpful to just say
this
i do not see this directly appearing in
my integral so it's not a nice loop like
i'll just swap this out what could i do
instead
um factor i square it eventually
if i factorize the square root of x oh
over here
yeah okay so if i take a factor of the
square root of x out
what i'll end up with is one on square
root of x
out the front i should write this down
because i'll try and do that okay
here's my integral one on the square
root of x and then what do you get
inside
and then it's like another fraction one
on high brackets
like so okay is this better
[Music]
do you agree i see a lot of knotting
right it it does work you actually will
get there you'll be fine
i'm gonna hit pause on this piece of
working because i wonder if actually
we're always looking for a lazier way
right um and you're going to see a
really laser
come to this third one i wonder if
there's an actual easier way to go about
this
um the reason why this is problematic is
because of this root x in the
denominator which i don't see over here
so to solve that problem your suggestion
is we add over here which
does work okay um many paths do these
integral questions right
but i wonder if there's some other way
that i can get it over here that makes
it easier to substitute
in for example or actually john do you
want
this suggestion yeah i will try because
we got a 2 x and we know that u
equal root x so we can actually
say that 2 x is equal to u okay and then
we know
that b bx is actually equal to
okay okay did you just catch what gia
you just did then because it was a
little bit different this is the move we
didn't have to pull
last time right what yeah he's
recognized is another square of x in
this denominator and you're like ah
gross i'm gonna have to change my
integrand somehow which is doable i
sometimes have to do that
but i notice that root x is something
i've already defined in the question
like i've defined it as you could it be
useful to me
to make that substitution back well
actually it turns out it's phenomenally
useful because
in this case here i can say oh my
two u d u and my dx can be quite neatly
separated do you see that which makes it
quite easy to go straight back
into here this is one last piece i'm
missing though i've got a dx
there it is i've got a square root of x
that's what i introduced i've got this
final turkey which i don't have a direct
it can be clear these are both going to
work but let's see maybe if you want to
make a comparison if you did this orange
line of working
just compare it to how things went uh or
how things are about to go with this one
let's go ahead and do the substitution
2ud on the top uh what do we just say
x squared plus sorry u
u squared that's what i'm doing uh plus
u right
what kind of difference
i have a common factor of u on the
numerator and denominator so that gives
me
i'm actually going to put two out front
one on
u plus one do you well
this looks like this is an f dash on
yeah isn't it or
yeah so i'm going to get two times
the log of absolute value of u plus one
i'm going to be lays into the um
here now we reflexively put in the
absolute value science
right why do we do that
it's birth words
[Music]
yeah i'm missing it that's okay i'm
going to come back to that why are we
putting the absolute value sides
so a common answer to this is logs can't
be negative
right yes can't be negative so you can't
take just going to park that thought
there
right logs can't be negative it's a good
first place to begin
but it can't be the last place that's i
just got a part that's a bigger thought
man
i'm mistaking the wrong substitution
this is plus one right
right yeah okay
are you happy with that look okay
i'm recently okay with that if you
wanted to in fact in this particular
case this question about logs right
um i would say the absolute value is a
bit superfluous isn't it
this is always going to be positive so
i'd be okay if it wasn't there
i have a question yes if you defined u
squared equals x as your first line is
that a problem
if we began here rather than
where we did begin does that lead to any
problems
oh okay so to try and get to something
over here right
i have i could try and do this stupid in
fact i will in a second
do this derivative but it's it's not
really written as
uh u as a function of x it's more
written as x as a function of
u so it would be more natural to
actually in this case work out dx onto u
rather than to u
on dx again somewhat similar to this
that doesn't necessarily
lead to problems but you do have to
consider what you're doing run just
reflectively reflexively differentiate
with respect to x so there's an issue
mrs liz did you want to point out any
other issues i'd hope they would
have a second what do you think uh well
what is
do bad substitution you'll lead to you
equal to plus minus right now so
um this comes back to this question i
ask them here are absolute values right
your choices substitute you're so
so black and white about things when you
choose a bad substitution i'm going to
say
less good substitution when you choose a
substitution
let's say for example this is the issue
we would talk about i just didn't use
the language right
this is no longer a function is it it's
actually a relation if you were to graph
this is that sideways
parabola okay when you do that you now
have two cases to contemplate
this is not a deal breaker sometimes
that's the best way to do things
but if we can avoid it that would be
nice right i would rather not have to
worry about
two cases as i integrate if i can
possibly avoid it
i should point out there are ways even
to escape it from here
for example um you know what we're doing
in here we had
all this negative index stuff flying
around you can actually avoid dealing
with negative indices if you do
this right you just have to be a little
careful about it
we suggested that you could do dx onto u
you could integrate sorry differentiate
this
with respect to this it's not the only
way you can go about this
you could still if you wanted
differentiate both sides
with respect to x it just looks a little
bit weird we can handle it though
watch carefully we'll do the right hand
side first because it's easier what is
the derivative of
x with respect to x that's just one
line change right so far so good when
you have a look at the left hand side
we're differentiating with respect to x
this thing now this thing itself
is a function right this is some
function
raised to a power i have a rule for this
when i have a function
of a function don't i what would i do to
this
maybe if i wrote it like this
it might be a little more obvious
because
that's what it is right
this is the chain rule isn't it this u
even though we're writing it just as a
prenumeral
it's short for you as a function of x
right so therefore how do i do training
there's just two bits ago right i've got
to deal with the
inside and then i'm going to deal with
the outside not that it matters which
one you said outside first let's have
you got that
it's something squared so when you
differentiate something squared what do
you do
two times two right that power comes
down to the front
and then you reduce the power by one so
far so good
but that's just the outside what do i
then fold down
in this case what would i do i would do
the inside derivative
in this case that would be f dash of x
here
the inside function is u right you see
that that's the inside function
this is the outside function but just u
is the inside function so i would write
that as
d u on dx see that
that's the derivative of the inside
function i could say that it's use ash
if you like the reason i'm not is
because i need to get to somewhere that
can
let me this is all in vitamin c notation
not
function notation right do you see how
close this is to what i just wrote
over here in fact i am not even going to
write the next line
right do you see i just need to multiply
through by dx because in this context
i can treat this as a fraction if you've
never seen something
like this before you could be forgiven
for it you should jump down it has a
special name
it's called implicit
differentiation because the thing that
you want the du
on dx which is what i tried to lead with
over here
it almost pops up just kind of like on
the side there it's implied
um we were differentiating with respect
to some variable that i wasn't in terms
of
right this is in terms of u i
differentiated with respect to x
so you could have done this you just had
to be careful about it
any fundamentally before i go and finish
them i think you also need to define as
x greater than zero
yes i have a i have a domain problem
here right so thankfully back in our
regional question do you have a domain
restriction imply
in the question you don't have to say
anything well
we do have to say we're not complex
numbers but that's implied when
everything's in terms of x's instead of
z's
so that therefore implies okay x is
greater than zero
and domain restrictions by the way are
going to become even more important
when we have a look at our third
question over here